we just received another bunch of
uh vaccinates
vaccines last saturday
and people are already
clamoring for the same because we have
realized
that with that vaccines there's not much
we can do
to even begin to rise
in terms of health issues
economic issues and of course education
so with 15
hundred people already dead and
the third wave afflicting many
we need more vaccines and
it's not right for developed nations to
see it on millions of vaccines
when we need them in africa and malawi
particularly
at this stage malawi is
a particularly poor country we know that
how hard
have you found it to actually access the
vaccines
it's been very hard through the kovacs
facility
and we trust that even the million
vaccines given there already when you
look at
the huge populations in africa
it's not right that we could
not access these vaccines vaccine
accessibility and equitability needs to
really be looked at seriously because no
one is safe until everybody else is safe
linked to kovid of course is aid
and malawi has been a a country that has
received uk
aid in the past we know that the uk is
now cutting its a budget
what impact do you fear that that is
going to have in malawi
we have been assured that that will not
affect
malawi's position and so i'm greatly
thankful
to prime minister johnson because of
that assurance
i know that we do need more aid
particularly
in the education sector and what this
particular conference has done is to
give us more resolve
because we are putting education
at the highest position
in terms of investment so that
even in our budget the sector has
received the highest amount of
funds to make sure that we have a
human power resource for the dream that
we have
of an inclusive wealthy uh self-reliant
nation
does this this foreign aid um you know
it obviously has
has an impact on what you as a country
are able to to do but
a lot of a lot of the reasoning and the
thought behind
such aid going into things like
education is that it's all about
soft power it's all about uh the uk
being known throughout the world as a
country that does this
do you think many people in malawi are
aware
of where the aid actually comes from or
or are they just grateful to be
receiving it
oh they are well aware of where that aid
comes from because
they get informed and they have access
to information
uh in a way that nothing would be
done behind any uh scene so
we are actually grateful the investment
is almost like uh i agree with
prime minister boris johnson that this
is a silver bullet
because if we want to make sure that the
whole world gets educated
then even those that run away from
africa in search of better places here
illegal immigrants here usually it's
because
in their countries there is not much
opportunity for
education and so if we can do this
this will solve a huge amount of other
problems
how important do you feel is
specifically for girls education because
it is girls that that fall out of the
education system much earlier than boys
42 percent of girls in malawi are
married before the age of 18
which is has now been made illegal
but but of course you know once they
fall pregnant once they
they you know get married they leave the
education system entirely
how are you going to try to reverse that
well number one we have passed
legislation to make it illegal for them
to get
married early and number two we want to
find ways
that will keep them in school for at
least 12
years and this is one of the things that
we're doing
to make sure that we have infrastructure
that is
conducive to girls continuing with
education
and the community secretary schools that
we have built
we want to make sure that girls don't
have to travel that far
to access education
and therefore we want to make sure we
have girls hostels
by the schools teachers are there
readily available and we take care of
them
the girl child has proven to be
the one that has fallen victim
particularly in this coffee 19
pandemic context with sexual
exploitation many of them fallen
pregnant those that we have been able to
rescue
even from early marriages we said go
back to school
because if we do train that girl child
and stays in school
it will resolve a whole lot of issues to
do with population
boom because they will have taken
responsibility
for their life and so we want to make
that an emphasis the girl
child needs to stay in school for as
long as it takes
how hard do you think it's going to be
to change society in malawi
to give it that emphasis to make people
recognize that
the girls leaving the education system
so early has a has a massively
detrimental effect on on the economy and
the country as a whole
we're already doing that we have uh
traditional leaders that are becoming
champions of this
and we have uh influencers in society
and we are dealing with
leaders of churches and religious
organizations
to make sure that everyone is on the
same page
and then as government let's make
resources available
let's make sure that we encourage
uh everyone to participate in this
malawi will never develop if we cannot
have
the girl child particularly now we want
to train all children but like you have
correctly observed it is the girl child
that has been lagging behind
and just a final thought from you
climate change it's something
uh you know we look at a lot here on sky
news
um malawi like like many countries is
being affected
the the problem seems to be a lot of the
time that in the developing world and in
lots of countries in africa
that there isn't the funds to to attack
climate change because as you rightly
you know pointed out there are so in
society so many fundamental problems
surrounding poverty and education
what would you like the western world
the the developed world as some would
call it
to do to help you and malawi on the
issue of climate change
we would like investment in biofuels
investment in a way that makes it easier
for malawians
majority of whom rely for example on
fuel a wood fuel for cooking and other
things
if we can have real investment that
takes or makes it easier for a family
to cook their food and they're not using
wood
that would be great and so biofuels
this is where we want to look at and we
will re-effort
uh issue uh
cases where forests are being
replenished
so that we don't lag behind this issue
of climate change has affected
us and uh irregular rain
patterns have affected us badly but
through it all we are having to
take measures where food sufficiency
becomes foremost
but we need to make sure that people do
have
capacity to cook that food to feed
themselves
and so investment in biofuels
will be the biggest issue we need now
interesting stuff well it's been a
pleasure to talk to you lazarus chakura
the president of malawi thank you for
your time today on sky news